ofcom has ruled that good morning
britain was not in breach of the
broadcasting code over piers morgan's
controversial comments about the duchess
of sussex the regulator received more
than 50 000 complaints about mr morgan's
comments on the program in march
including from the duchess herself our
royal correspondent rhiannon mills has
the latest
i think it's worth reminding ourselves
that this all came about because of that
explosive interview that was broadcast
back in in march this year which caused
a huge amount of debate
and made those very damaging claims
again royal family in terms of racism
and also suggested that at times she'd
been suicidal and significantly
struggling with her mental health and
yet the royal family offered um no
support of course has caused a huge
amount of debate over in the states and
back here in the uk
and one person that waded into that
debate was up here's morgan now the
morning after the interview he said that
he didn't believe uh megan's claims and
as a result ofcom received an enormous
number of complaints 50 000 complaints
in total making it apparently the most
complained about moment in the watchdogs
history also we know that megan directly
wrote a complaint
to itv as well because those comments
made by um piers morgan however today we
can read you now the statement that's
been released by
ofcom in which they have set in the
particular circumstances we considered
the broadcaster provided adequate
from potentially harmful and highly
offensive statements about mental health
and suicide as there was sufficient
challenge to such statements which meant
they were adequately contextualized they
also went on to say that we also
consider statements made in the program
about race and racism had the potential
to be highly offensive to some viewers
however in the particular circumstances
of this case they were sufficiently
well our decision is that the program
did not breach the ofcom broadcasting
code now you will not be surprised to
hear that piers morgan very quickly has
taken twitter to um give his reaction uh
to ofcom's verdict on twitter he has
said uh i'm delighted ofcom has endorsed
my right to disbelieve the duke and
duchess of sussex's incendiary claims to
oprah winfrey many of which have proven
to be untrue this is a resounding
victory for free speech and a resounding
defeat for princess pinocchio's
so we wait to see exactly what itv are
going to say in response to the ofcom
ruling and yes as i said wait to see
whether the duchess of sussex has
anything further to say about it as well
you